cutting it super close
the corner over there yeah
shopping in there
one group of friends
I thought she's like she runs the place
she's good yeah when he got
for some reason I thought that won't
look better yeah yeah but looking at
okay bye
yeah yeah yeah yeah perfect weather
you're the best
yeah cuz that's the back one yeah
doing these there zone - oh give me that
one first really for sure send me down
dammit
this looks like what did that slum you
have a different eye than I do
why is this place so special Comedy
Store my man yeah the queer yeah
the world that stuff meaning there's
more tradition the state will be on the
second floor there Justin that's what
you carry was that yeah what your prior
and we get me
that everyone just in the screen it's
like all the original analog original
stuff all the legends and I explained
everybody who was here this exactly
like just the tradition and the legacy
you can feel like you're walking home
together
I just feel something yeah when you go
through those curves it was a scene
Kurtis Jim Carrey went through the same
curtains you know Jerry Seinfeld has
been to before
I've had tryouts so after all the shows
you guys come in and just chill the road
doing all our boys yeah but for how long
it took what if we're all the same show
just sort of don't come back here
it was a cool hangout spot over there
the reason sources clearly there's a ton
of like hey and like you're not you know
the general public that there's spaces
to hang all year there's Brian itself
everybody here we are kids we have known
in a long time it's a work site
right you're right it's a prank
oh I'm sorry did you kill a bull dr.
John makes like know you like the
officer to infinity and I don't I'm just
set by that guy
why can't you slide by things like this
three flat clear cuz it makes you look
thicker you know what - this is Tommy
don't be so nervous
ah so nervous have to always never pet
baby baby baby come on baby baby birth
don't get out of the nest
baby Brits get when they grow up they
want fly yeah I read five baby you hurt
like to know what will change or break
that's it no sweaty gives me leaders on
yeah
good man it's been in office since
you've been that you know your your
lanterns that you gave us they came in
handy yeah yeah we had like a blackout
in the studio twice okay and then we
were able to film the episodes because
of those lamps oh so we thank you so
much for the buzz this year we hope that
we'll get water to over 200,000 evils so
badass dude I've seen bigger more
intimidating because you have a jacket
on and you kind of like you don't have
at all any aggressive hair you're more
of a healer but like he's a guy that you
would kind of be like this [ __ ] guy
bro you know you'd be like dude and then
it'd be a problem sure that our breath
no yes he is I know that if you fight
anyway professionally
that's Brendon and Brian understand
oh [ __ ] Stevie what's up big how you
been man miss your buddy yeah my buddy's
here to come support him you know I'm
always there for me
hey you know I miss the beginning the
beginnings by now
hold on all right I'm gonna give him one
nice compliment I'm gonna give him one
nice compliment he deserves it I'm gonna
just say this now what is the only thing
I'm gonna say I think your extensions
look really good they look Wow
it's real hair yes it is it's real weed
but it's right
[ __ ]
nice
that's celebrating yourself I love how
like [ __ ] two-thirds of you know who
I am but the other people are like
person that said that goddamn are they
really yes there are you know Andy thank
you so much hardly afford this like I
said I took a lot of my mom
that was an accident
I know I asked you to do it
how do we get that stink
- me
here's a fan that I fight her in the kid
you do never [ __ ]
yes
once again
love you guys
if I